semaine décisive également pour le
mouvement universitaire françois bayrou
recevra demain dimanche les
représentants de la coordination
étudiante qui s'est réunie jusqu'à 4
heures du matin à censier pour élaborer
sa plateforme revendicatrice et pour
composer après des manoeuvres de
coulisses pas toujours très claires la
délégation qui soit reçue au ministère
françoise david c'était hier soir à la
faculté de censier environ 300
représentants d'universités en grève
s'étaient retrouvés pour élaborer une
plate forme de revendications a présenté
au ministre de l'éducation nationale
les étudiants exigent en urgence deux
milliards de francs pour assurer les
travaux de réfection des bâtiments
anciens et également deux milliards de
francs pour le fonctionnement mais il
pense aussi à un avenir proche
nous lui demandons une map programmation
budgétaire quinquennal savoir que on lui
demande la création de 25 postes
d'enseignants chercheurs de 20000 postes
de personnels techniques et
administratifs
on lui demande si cette programmation la
chiffre à 50 milliards de francs les
étudiants qui tenait en fin d'après midi
une nouvelle réunion réclame également
la réquisition des universités privées
il appelle à la grève générale dans les
universités et à des manifestations
mardi prochain délégation qui
rencontrera demain matin au ministère de
l'éducation nationale françois bayroux
est composé de vingt-deux délai d un
tiers de parisiens et deux tiers de
provinciaux mais hier soir une certaine
confusion a régné lors de la désignation
de ses délégués et ce soir l'unef
indépendante et démocratique syndicats
qui majoritaire dans universités appelle
je cite les étudiants à rester vigilants
face à toute tentative de récupération
politique